hi there steve kaufman here today i want
to talk about um accents
it's a subject that comes up all the
time which accent should we learn does
it matter for example in spanish in
english and french and
in all languages there are different
accents which accent should we learn
does it matter
things of this nature
it comes up to some extent because i'm
going to latin america i had a
conversation and we were talking about
different accents you know argentinian
mexican spanish and of course the same
is true in english we have you know
american north american southern
scottish australian
what about all this stuff before i get
into that though
i just want to confirm again that you
know i'm going to be in south america
and i'm happy to have meetups or meet
with people talk about language learning
but i'm going to be traveling with my
wife and another couple so the best of
course is if people there who want to
get together organize something let me
know and then we can find something that
works
the dates i'm going to put them in i'm
going to put a link in fact in the
description box to a thread at our forum
at link lingq
where i ask people to let me know if
they want to get together and the dates
are buenos aires basically what's
available is october 3 or 4
or october 8 9 10 in buenos aires in rio
it's october 13 to 17. salvador october
18 and 19 and lima october 26 through
28th so check the link and let me know
if you want to get together
accents
it also came up because apparently
there's a dispute not a dispute but
there are
uh teachers who are non-native speaking
teachers mostly of english who feel that
they are somehow treated unfairly
and uh
and so then there was a comment about is
there any evidence that if a teacher has
an accent that it could be that it could
adversely affect the learner
or if a non-native speaking teacher of
english or any language makes a mistake
would that adversely affect the learner
so
kind of throwing these things all
together
uh i think that any one teacher
any one source of audio or text any
mistake has very little impact over the
course of your learning people get all
bent out of shape because there's some
incorrect uh you know grammar in some
text somewhere that a learner is using
it doesn't really matter in my opinion
because i know in my own experience i'm
i you know i'm exposed to so much
material so many different people so
many and even native speakers make
mistakes
so that in the end it doesn't matter as
long as you do enough listening and
reading it won't matter much and and
when we deal with the issue of accents
um
you know i i must admit that when i
learn another language initially i'm not
that aware of different accents i'm
focused on words and meaning
and
many learners i would think of spanish
in an initial period have trouble
telling whether it's from spain or from
mexico or from colombia or whatever and
that in time they become more aware of
these differences in pronunciation
they may find some people easier to
understand than others it might be how
quickly they speak or whatever but then
in time
if a person really wants to speak he's
going to live in colombia he wants to
speak like a colombian wants to
understand the colombians then at some
point it's probably a good idea to focus
on
the accent
that is most useful for you if you're
going to be working in quebec then you
should probably focus on making sure you
understand the accent in quebec and
probably you want to sound a little bit
more like a quebecer because that will
be more
you know um
sympathetic from the perspective of the
people you're dealing with so it really
depends on what your needs are
uh
you know and so therefore at one at some
point you you probably should focus on
on one form
one accent and try to really get into
the rhythm and the intonation and the
pronunciation of that accent but that
doesn't mean that you shouldn't listen
to other accents
because uh you know acquiring words and
acquiring a familiarity with the
language is kind of the basic task
so that uh
and and plus you should even if you're
going to be living in argentina you
should be able to understand people from
spain or chile
if you're going to be living in
you know australia you should still be
able to understand people from scotland
so it's useful to also expose yourself
to these other accents in my view and
certainly in the beginning i don't think
it matters very much but at some point
as a strategy
you may say okay i want to focus on
this form of the language because that's
where i'm going to be and that's what's
going to be most useful for me um
i'll just touching briefly on this idea
of non-native speaking teachers i mean
there is
people have prejudices
so i i'm sure there are situations where
a school would rather
like in japan
that they might prefer to have a
dutchman with his dutch accent as
opposed to a native speaker who looks
asian say an asian canadian which is of
course extremely unfair and and and
demonstrates prejudice on the part of
the school but maybe they feel i'm
learning english that's language of the
white people therefore i want a teacher
who's of european origin which of course
is silly however
you know if you're learning say chinese
uh would you rather learn from someone
who looks european
or someone who looks
chinese
uh
now of course if they both if they are
both non-native speakers personally i
would make no difference i i prefer to
learn from native speakers
i find it more motivating to learn from
native speakers because to me the
learning process is largely listening
and reading and any questions i have on
grammar or usage i can look them up and
then i go back to doing my listening and
reading
and then at some point i want to engage
people in conversation and it's more
motivating for me to be doing this with
a native speaker
but in a classroom where you have a
teacher who's trying to encourage people
motivate them stimulate them inspire
them help them pick them up when they
feel frustrated
i don't think it really matters whether
it's a native speaker and not a speaker
i don't think these things matter i
think
for the independent learner we should
respect the choice of the independent
learner like me i just find that if i
get the language from a native speaker
that to me is just more credible more
motivating more credible
so i would only listen to
audio
with a native speaker that's what turns
me on
i might consume content written by a
non-native speaker because i'm
interested in the subject matter but as
a deliberate choice in language learning
i would prefer the native speaker but
that's not to say that a non-native
speaker can't be very competent
in the language and we have many
examples of non-native speakers who use
say english better than many native
speakers i mean the one example that
pops to mind is of course joseph joseph
conrad who was a phenomenal
author in the english language i know
apparently had a polish uh accent until
the end of his days
so i mean it's it's the language
i can't immediately think of them but
there are well samuel beckett who is an
irishman he wrote in french
so anyone can learn to use a language
very well and theoretically can teach
the language as well as say a native
speaker but i think we also should
respect
the motivation and the preferences of
the learner so there you have it i
what i did today was i talked briefly
about my uh trip to south america
please check the link if you're
interested in participating in some kind
of a gathering in one of those cities
please come to our forum at link you'll
see a link to link
i talked about you know accents and why
i think people make too much of a of a
deal about it when they're starting out
whereas at a later stage they should
probably focus on the the form of the
language that's going to be most useful
for them and then i touched briefly on
this controversy surrounding non-native
speakers of the language so a bit of a
ramble
and i hope to see some of you in south
america bye for now
[Music]
you